από απόσταση την αντιπεραόχθει αυτός ευαισθητοποί και νομίζω ότι με που εδωσ κάποιες επιπλέν δυνατότητες
να αντιλιφθώ τα σοβορά προβλήματα τα οποία δημειοργή οι διάγνωση και οιθα αναποία των κακοηθειών
όχι μόνων ια των ασθενή αλλά και για τω κοινωνικώ περιβάλλο το κενικώ νικόν περιβάλλων
του ασθενώς υποφέρι και αυτό έχει τροπερές συναι επίες ς και αυτό τοντιμετωπίζουμε ή το
λαμβάνουμε νυπόψει ι διαίτερα εμείς οιγιατρει αι ίσως όχι με την απειτούμενη α υαισθυσία εδώ
χρειαζόύμαστε όλοι αζόμαστε και εγώ ακόμα αραισως γατρα ριότε βελτίωση άραισως αυτά τα βιώματα που
ζήσατα εκίνη την περίοδο σας ε κάνε να αλλάξετε κάποια πράγματα είτε στο πως τωνανακοινώνετε
του ασθενή σσαση με των να σας πωυ συγκεκριμένα με ευαισθιτοποίς στα προβλήματα που αντιμετωποίζων
τα παιδιά ασθενών μεκαρκίνω αυτό είναι μια πτυχή σκοτινή πτυχή της οκολογικής καθημερινότητας όλοι επικεντρόνωνται
στων ασθενή τα παιδιά έχουν τι δικές τους ανισυχίες τις δικές τς ανασφάλειες αντιμετωπίζουντα προβλήματα
στο σχολείω στον περιβάλλων και αυτά όλα μένων σκοτεινά